Thank you. So we are going to start
the panel sessions.
And this year,
as you will see from our schedule,
the theme of the faculty panels is
Establishing Your Professional Identity.
And I'm delighted in particular
to be able to introduce
the panelists that we have
for this morning to you.
They are individuals who have managed
to figure out the system that is Harvard
and who have gone through the process
of being promoted here at Harvard.
And I hope that they will be able
to give you some insights
about the ways in which these
processes occur at this institution.
So we have three associate
professors in the first panel
and I'd like to
introduce them briefly.
They will each have 10 minutes
to make remarks
and then we will have plenty of time
at the end
for conversation, discussion,
questions and answers, et cetera.
So our first panelist
is Nonie Lesaux.
She is the Marie and Max Kargman
Associate Professor in Human Development
and Urban Education Advancement
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
Dr. Lesaux leads a research program
that focuses on the reading development
and difficulties of children
from linguistically diverse backgrounds.
Her developmental and
instructional research
has implications for practitioners,
researchers, and policy makers.
From 2004 to 2006,
Nonie was Senior Research Associate
of the National Literacy Panel
on Language Minority Youth
and named one of five
William T. Grant Scholars
earning a $350,000 five-year award
from the W.T. Grant Foundation
in support of her research
on English language learners
in urban public schools.
Dr. Lesaux is a member
of the Society
for the Scientific Study of Reading,
International Academy for Research
in Learning Disabilities,
Society for Research in Child Development,
and many other
distinguished organizations.
She is also a member of the
Reading First Advisory Committee
for the Secretary of Education,
the U.S. Department of Education.
Dr. Lesaux received her PhD.
at University of British Columbia,
and I'm pleased to say that
she recently received the
Presidential Early Career Award
for Scientists and Engineers
awarded by the White House in 2009.
Our second panelist is
Dr. Juan C. Celedon
who is Associate Professor of Medicine
at Harvard Medical School
as well as Associate Physician
at Brigham and Women's Hospital.
Dr. Celedon's primary area of research
is to identify genetic factors
and environmental exposure
that influence the development
of obstructive airway diseases
asthma and chronic obstructive,
pulmonary diseases
in general and among
Hispanics in particular.
Juan currently leads
three NIH-funded studies
of the genetics of obstructive airway diseases
in individuals of Hispanic descent.
Two of these studies
employ a family-based design
to examine the relation between
genetic factors and asthma and COPD
in an isolated Hispanic population
living in the central valley of Costa Rica.
And the third study
uses a case control design
to examine the relation
among genes,
indoor allergen exposure and asthma
phenotypes among Puerto Rican children.
Dr. Celedon has been leading a
study of the relation between--
also between the maternal and neonatal
gut flora and asthma and allergic diseases.
He received his medical degree
from Bogota, Columbia in 1988,
and then PH in Quantitative
Methods in 1999,
and a DPH in Genetic Epidemiology in 2001
from the Harvard School of Public Health.
Our third panelist is Sarah
Stewart-Mukhopadhyay,
who is the John Loeb Associate Professor
of the Natural Sciences.
Her research focuses on collisional processes
including planet formation,
catastrophic disruption and
surface modification.
Laboratory measurements
of the equation of state
and dynamic strength
of planetary materials
using shockwave techniques,
as well as experimental and computational
studies of impact processes
to interpret the resurfacing
history, physical properties
and internal structure of planets,
moons, asteroids and comets.
Dr. Stewart-Mukhopadhyay
is a Director
of the Shock Compression
Laboratory at Harvard.
She received her PhD in Planetary Sciences
with a minor in Astrophysics from
Caltech in Pasadena in 2002,
and her AB in astronomy
and astrophysics
and physics here at
Harvard University.
Prior to coming to Harvard, she was a
Carnegie Post-Doc Fellow
at the Carnegie Institution
in Washington, D.C.
And among her many numerous honors,
Dr. Stewart-Mukhopadhyay
also received the Presidential
Early Career Award
for Scientists and Engineers in 2004,
and received most recently
the Harold Urey Prize in 2009.
So we will first start with Dr. Lesaux
and we'll move forward from there.
Thanks.
I heard somebody say
we figured out Harvard
and I felt maybe I should go back
to that side of the room.
But thanks for the invite.
I think, you know,
I'll start with two kind of caveats
that are really inherent
in this sort of exercise.
And the first is there is
something extremely personal
about the experience
of being an academic,
of being a member
of an academic community.
And so you do know yourself
and your circumstances best,
and those are really in some ways
your best guides,
so that's sort of one caveat.
The second is that
the methodologist in me says,
"Well, this retrospective
analysis, the sort of looking back,
is always a kind of
dangerous venture."
But with those caveats in mind,
I really just thought about three things
that I think you might consider
as you go forward.
And the first is really
that in some ways,
it's kind of the keep it
simple factor, which is
--I'm sort of continually
struck by the fact
that the recipe for
early career success is sort of
remarkably simple
and straightforward.
And that's not that it's not difficult
and that it doesn't
bear on level of effort,
but that the actual ingredients that
kind of go into early career success
are the same ones that probably
you heard about in grad school.
They're the same ones
that drove your hire here,
the reason that
you're sitting here.
So my sort of sense is that you
just need to stay really caught up
in your personal professional plan
that you are people with strong
ideas about your professional life.
You had a plan by
virtue of the doctorate
and applying here, and that plan
sells you and others around you.
You've thought about
the way you teach,
you've made a choice about
the academic routes.
So as you kind of move forward,
sort of remember that
you do have that plan
and you have that in your
hand still as you begin your career.
And at the same time,
what you don't want to do,
so you want to get caught up
in your own plan,
and what you don't want to do
is get totally caught up
doubting or second-guessing yourself
by virtue of watching
those around you,
by hearing about what's reportedly
working better for them.
You know, you want to
get some insights
but not to worry so much about
the roads that others are taking
because in fact there are so many roads
to a successful career.
And keep in mind that
as President Faust said,
there are so many
supports here to--
that in some ways you do have
that advantage of really,
truly carrying out your plans
because as you refine and develop
your skills and ideas,
you've got these tremendous supports
around here to do that;
both in the research realm
and in the teaching realm.
So kind of concrete things about this
straightforward sort of recipe
for high impact solid
work and good teaching:
I'd say every now and again
reread the statement that you wrote
when you applied here.
Every now and again just reread it
and see how it's working for you,
what's working for you.
I've done that since writing
my statement for associate,
for promotion to associate.
It's a very clarifying
experience, right,
when one sets out their plans
and their philosophy
about their teaching
and their goals.
And so reread that
every now and again.
The second thing is, and this
sort of feeds into this slight
tension between collaboration
and trying to carve out what's yours,
but I personally looking back and again,
this is sort of the two cents -
I think try to get
something that's truly yours
in the first several years
that you're here.
And I don't say that like it can't
be part of collaborative work
but I do think that early on it
makes sense to have a project
or some kind of initiative
that feels like yours.
And I'm not--you know that might
be a grant to carry out a study,
it might be a book contract, it might
be launching some kind of initiative.
And here I'm really not
talking about the politics
or sort of playing your cards,
but I am sort of
thinking that there are
things that you need to
do to establish yourself
but also to give yourself that
added confidence to really say
"This is kind of what
I'm working on."
Even if it's a piece of an overall
collaborative endeavor
it can kind of keep you,
pushing forward.
And so even in a collaborative,
sort of, interdisciplinary approach,
there are still ways to kind of carve
out pieces that are yours.
And in so, in my case, for example,
I got a small grant from the NICHD,
from the National Institute of Health
in my second year,
late in my second year.
And it just kind of practically speaking
gave me a boost.
I hired some students
who were here on campus.
The money was here at Harvard.
It was my account.
But it was also just a
boost for my career.
It was kind of a push
in the right direction.
And so it doesn't have to be
all that you're doing,
it doesn't have to
be monumental,
but it's something that you feel like
is yours early on.
And finally, on this sort of
straightforward piece I'd say,
you know, I think stay as close as
you can to your research and teaching.
Presumably you didn't do a PhD
to kind of think a lot about the
administration of the organization,
and so I would say if you can
keep the politics at an arm's length
and I actually, again, don't say this
so much with politics per se in mind,
but I do say it with
your own time in mind;
which is that, you know, in part
I can almost guarantee
that in the next
several years somebody -
a dean or a department chair
or a member of senior faculty -
will tap you on the shoulder to do
something in particular,
some additional service,
your participation in a new initiative
that they're launching,
the development of
some kind of new course,
kind of getting a course off out of the
brackets and back on to the books.
And it is additional. Those kinds
of endeavors can be intensive.
You will say yes when that
happens because you just will.
And so what you want to do is feel
like that's actually time well spent
and feel like that's sort
of your chance to be--
to shape something new to contribute
to the organization, to be seen.
And it ends up being
constructive and productive.
And so keep that in mind
as you go forward,
is that probably there'll be a time
into the administration
of the organization.
So that's sort of a little
about the recipe.
The second thing that I really
want to kind of push a little bit on
is that this really is a marathon.
It's really not a sprint.
And so don't come out of the gates and
empty the tank in a really short time
because you are really
going to need to pace
yourselves over
the next several years.
And so I think that
can be really tricky
particularly when, you know,
by year two you're
preparing a package
that is for review.
But ultimately, this is kind
of a long range enterprise.
Whether you're here or
at any other institution,
the academic enterprise is one
that sort of takes time.
And to really develop good
ideas and do really solid work,
you do need the time but you
also need to pace yourself.
And so I sort of think of it two ways;
both practically, this isn't a marathon--
or sorry, this is not a sprint--but
also intellectually it's not a sprint,
which is that you don't want to spread,
you don't want to get so involved.
It's very easy to kind of have this,
your hand in this and this and this,
and not to be going sort of
deep in sort of one particular area
or tackling one particular problem.
So think not just about the next
one or two years
but try to think even
five, seven, ten years out.
Probably five or seven is really
where you're going to
be most comfortable.
And you want to think about
different priorities at different stages
so that some semesters become
much more about your teaching
than they do about your research,
and other semesters become
much more about the
funding for proposals
and that kind of thing.
And you just want to be sort of
pacing yourself so that you're not
trying to work on
everything all at once.
And, um, you know, it really does
work for me to liken my junior years.
I'm now in year
seven to the marathon
which is one of
the two big mistakes
one makes when
they run a race poorly.
One is you start out too fast.
The second is you start
to lose focus about half,
two-thirds of the way through.
You kind of have to dig deep,
stay really focused
mentally and keep pushing.
And ultimately, you need
something left in the tank.
So if we take the
five or seven-year plan,
I would say what
happens is over time,
in some ways the years right
now can feel the most stressful
at some level because
the place is new,
because you're adjusting,
because it's--
you're sort of you
haven't figured it all out,
you're kind of getting a sense of
the institution but also
the job of an academic.
So there is that stress
associated with the newness.
But by virtue of your
advancing career over time,
what happens is your load
kind of very gradually
but very steadily increases and
becomes heavier and heavier, right?
And so in my case, for example,
right over there across the street,
there's two post-docs, three
fulltime research associates,
several doc students,
two large federal grants,
uh, big projects and research
assistants across the country
that we're working with. And that's
just a part of my picture, right,
that's the research side,
which is fine beacause, you know,
as most people advance their
careers, that's going to happen.
The key is that in academia,
you've got these mechanisms
where actually you can find time.
And so my concrete suggestion
is to be thinking ahead
about the grants and fellowships
that really do buy out your time
and let you focus because as part
of establishing your reputation
is being able to carve out
the time to do the good work
and be part of intellectual communities here and elsewhere,
then the trick is to
find the time to do that.
So I'm not really the
person to tell you all
about the different fellowships
and grants in your particular fields,
but I will say to really think
through and do your research on
those tailored to early
career scholars.
So it doesn't mean that it has
to be practical money to do research.
It's often just money
to buy out your time.
And so what comes to mind for me
are awards like the
NSF Early Career Award,
the Robert Johnson Scholars
which is not for early careers
but it can be really well
used in the early career.
The W.T.Grant Foundation
Scholars Award,
which is one I have five--
that's a five-year award
that is sort of 50% of my time
every year which is significant.
Foundation for Child Development,
the Radcliffe Fellowships that
President Faust in part initiated.
There are a number
of initiatives like that
and folks around who know that.
Some of them come with mentoring,
some of them come with
networking opportunities,
and that's good
visibility. But mostly
you really want to stay
focused on finding the time.
And as you develop
those applications,
think a little bit about your timing
which is that it’s not--
it is often the case that
fellowships and
grants that kick in
and give you more
time kind of midpoint,
three--year three, four, five,
can be really, really valuable.
It’s also the case
that what happens is,
is sometimes the
time later actually
is directly related to
really high impact work
that’s going to affect, sort of,
your career going forward.
If you’re people with a
one-semester junior leave,
think too about
the timing for that
because it can be
tempting to use it early on
but it’s also the case that,
talk with several folks,
and myself included,
who are really happy
to have held on to that
until a little later
when it really does serve the
value of protecting your time.
So it’s not to say the next couple
of years aren’t important ones
because they are and you do
need to protect your time and
get your things done.
But think through not
exhausting all your, sort of,
bio and fellowship
opportunities early on.
Think about sort of pacing
yourselves in that sense.
And finally, I’ll just
say one last thing
which is the topic
for today is really
this professional identity piece.
And I think I’ll really
say two things here.
One is that you’re always constructing
your professional identity.
You’re always sort of casting yourself
in some kind of light here at Harvard
but also equally as importantly and I
think sometimes that’s easy to forget,
that you’re casting--
you are creating a
professional identity
outside of the
institution regularly -
in print and informally and
formally in conversation.
And so you want to be seen
as somebody who’s collegial,
who’s doing not just high
quality work but is of high integrity,
and who’s a good peer
across different settings and in and
outside the institution.
The concrete
suggestions, I mean, to be
establish a positive personal
and professional identity,
there are a few things.
One is you need the
supports to do that.
You need supports
professionally and personally.
inside of the institution
but you also need supports
outside of the institution.
So that in fact one of the
things I’d really recommend
is talking with others
at other institutions
about professional life
and kinds of issues
because it can really bring
a lot more perspective
to the way that you interpret
things that are happening here.
It can also give you
some really good ideas
about managing your
professional life.
So other juniors here
on campus but also
folks outside and at
other institutions.
And finally on mentoring
because this came up,
sort of, as one possible
topic for today:
I think mentoring is a tricky
thing and I’ll say that right flat-out.
I think it’s a human enterprise.
It’s one of relationships.
I think you can’t always
force relationships
as we know in our professional
and personal lives.
So mostly I think of it this way:
You have to be comfortable.
It has to be natural.
It has to be something
that evolves over time.
both the mentoring that you get
and your own mentoring
of others, right,
because already you’re going
to start to mentor folks here.
So I would say, you know, stay
with your plan, let it happen naturally.
As things progress, there’s going to
be people that you gravitate towards,
there’s going to be
people that you realize
where it’s really quality,
not quantity,
so you don’t need a lot of
contact with good mentors.
Some of the best mentorship
I’ve had is actually from someone
outside of the institution who’s a member
of the senior faculty elsewhere,
who I see very sporadically.
But, you know, 20, 30 minutes,
a drink at a conference,
a beer, can be really clarifying
and really helpful.
That’s sort of nothing formal
about that relationship,
nothing particularly
ongoing or frequent.
But when it happens, those
conversations are really helpful.
So I would really suggest
thinking about quality
and not quantity
and sort of seeing what emerges.
And you'll have a better sense
as time goes on of the kind of feedback
that you really need
and how to get that.
But it takes time.
I think good mentoring relationships
do take time to develop.
I’m going to stop there.
So, good morning.
It's truly an honor and a
privilege to be here.
It's also quite humbling especially
to our members of the panel.
I'd like to take a different path.
[Laughter]
So, you know I'm going to start
with a very wise statement
from the mother of Forrest Gump
in that Oscar-winning movie
which is "Life is a box of chocolates.
You never know what
you're going to get."
That summarizes my life today
So, I'm going--I believe
that each faculty member,
every one of you has a
unique set of life experiences
that ultimately will,
if it hasn't already,
profoundly influence
your academic career.
I'll have to tell you a little bit
about my life and then some more.
I was born in 1964 in
Barranquilla, Colombia.
That's a town on the Caribbean coast
of Colombia which is in Northwest-
most far of South America.
People born in the Caribbean,
which is the general region of the sea,
constitute one-third of the population
of Colombia which is about 40 million.
The last president to be born in the
Caribbean to be elected was in 1886.
We have over 122 years without
having a Caribbean president.
We are quite different.
Our culture, our accent is different.
The media, uh, often
reminds us of that.
We're stereotyped on a daily basis.
I was going to come
to the U.S. for college.
Those were my plans.
And when I was 15 my sister,
who was an economist at Harvard
, died in a car accident.
That was the first profound
event that influenced my life.
I have to change my plans.
I was the youngest of five siblings.
And instead of coming
here to the U.S.,
I had to go to the heart of
the Andes in Bogota, Colombia.
This is the second oldest
university in the Americas.
Yes, it is older than
Harvard University.
[Laughter]
It's a different school.
My class had 84 people; there were
only four people from the Caribbean.
There were times when a
professor would make a joke
which wasn't at all funny to us,
and my friends and I had to
bide our time and walk away.
We used that as motivation.
You always have to channel
your anger for positive things.
Of the four, three
graduated top of the class.
Two of us are in the States.
One of them is a world
authority in Straub.
So I decided that I wanted to
come to this country to do research.
And I sent 400
letters of application.
I applied to every program
in the United States
and territories including
one in Puerto Rico.
After sending 400 letters,
I got seven interviews.
One of these interviews
was at Lincoln Hospital
which is in the South Bronx -
that's the poorest congressional
district in this nation.
I took a taxi from Manhattan
there, and there
was this Dominican man
who was a philosopher.
He looked at me--had a tie,
had an overcoat--and he said,
"You look like a nice boy.
Why are you going to the Bronx?"
And I said, "You know
, I'm a foreigner.
There's a lot of very few places
who'd give me an interview.
He paused, looked at
me again and said,
"The whites are sending
you there to die".
[Laughter]
Although I did survive.
I saw firsthand the effects of
segregation, profound segregation.
Americans often act horrified
about violence elsewhere
but they don't look at places like
the Bronx, Harlem, the inner city.
Look in your own house.
I served an internship there
and then I went on to the
residency at Beth Israel New York.
And then I always tell my mentees
that you cannot control who your
parents are - that's a random event,
one that is either blessed or not.
But you can control who you
spend the rest of your life with.
So the best decision of
my life was to marry my wife.
[Laughter]
I say that without hesitation.
Then in 1995, I wanted to the state
and I had a visa called a J-1,
which is the worst visa you can have.
You're better off being an illegal alien.
[Laughter]
So I mailed again 400
letters of application.
I looked into every government
agency and I got one interview
which was at the Veterans Administration
Hospital in Newark, Pennsylvania
that's close to Toronto, Canada.
It's in the lakes. And I
served two years
for the government there as
an internist of pulmonologist,
and then they granted me
permanent residency in this country,
which is when I applied
to come to Harvard.
When I came here
as a research fellow,
I took a pay cut of 67%
before adjusting for cost of living.
My conservative estimation
was the pay cut was 80%
after you adjust for that.
My first child had been born.
I moonlighted 16 weekends in a row
to have the down payment for my
home which is still in Framingham,
far away from my place of work.
In 1999, I was about to
submit an application
for an entry level
grant to the NIH.
That was August.
I was taking a plane
to go to Costa Rica
where two of my research
projects are when my wife called.
And I said to my mentor, one
of my mentors who was with me,
I said to him "Did somebody die?
My wife would never call me
unless somebody died."
I thought of my second child who had
been born two weeks earlier than that.
But in fact my only brother had been
murdered by a psychopath
in a mass murder suicide,
a copycat of some of the events
in Atlanta and Seattle.
He killed three or four people and then
the guy blew his head.
And suddenly I had to deviate, go to
Colombia, and have two nephews,
11 and 8, come and embrace me
and realized that I was the
last male survivor of my family
since I had lost my
father seven years earlier.
I did submit my grant in any event.
And the grant did not get
funded but I resubmitted the grant,
and it was funded in 2001
when I also got my Doctorate
from the School of Public Health.
Subsequent to that, I
became an Assistant Professor.
I got two large grants
funded from NIH.
I was blessed getting
a mentoring award,
a teaching award
from medical school,
and I became an associate
professor in April of 2007.
So I'll give you my few
pieces of advice.
Santiago Ramon y
Cajal was a Spaniard
who won the Nobel Prize--
it was a Neural Science.
He summarized this -
I modified the slide a bit.
The first one is you have to have the capacity
to criticize the work of others,
but particularly your own.
The best advice
that I ever got was
"Never believe any data,
particularly your own."
Desire for originality -
you have to find noble
things as a function of academia.
Focus - that saved me.
You have very limited time.
You have to attend
to many different things.
You have to focus.
Honesty above all things even when temptations abound,
you have to love the truth.
Outstanding work habits.
Passion - you have to love what you do.
There'll be no doubt of that.
Spirit of service above all things.
The should of a physician
above all will serve others.
And perseverance,
the most important quality.
There are so many things
that I see for new faculty.
There are great opportunities.
There are outstanding educational
and training opportunities.
I took advantage
of several of those.
And that allows you to develop
a unique set of skills.
You have to set yourself apart.
At my place, most people go
for a Master's degree.
Nobody had done a doctorate.
But at the time I was doing that,
with two children and doing
all this moonlighting,
I realized that genetics was the
wave of the future.
And the only way I could get additional
training was by doing a Doctorate.
Many people thought I was crazy
and I am crazy. But I did it
Then you also have
outstanding trainees.
Many people think these people
sort of as disposable,
or people who can be recycled.
I view them very differently.
They are the life blood of my program.
If you treat your people well,
many of these people are extraordinary bright;
word of mouth will
bring more people to you.
And they come to you and
they want to work with you
because you provide a good environment
for them.
Never take them lightly.
You can also establish unbelievable
collaborations across campus.
There are also huge challenges.
When somebody's recruited here
particularly at the junior level
and particularly at the medical school,
the high cost of living in this city
cannot be forgotten.
I told you how much moonlighting
I had to do - that's a daily reality.
When you have somebody work for 30 hours
and then ask them to do something,
it's just quite difficult for them.
It's remarkable that they
can get to do something.
The quality of mentorship
varies enormously.
I'm talking about the
medical school again -
varies across institutions,
varies across departments;
it's highly variable
across divisions.
There are some people who
are outstanding mentors,
almost saints in their own way, but
there are also tormentors and dementors.
[Laughter]
As a minority, I have to say this.
I have said this openly.
There is a profound dearth of
under-represented minorities
in senior leadership positions.
It's appalling. It's depressing.
There are no division chiefs or
department chiefs in my own institution.
That has several negative effects.
It affects morale.
The number of Hispanic colleagues
that I've seen leaving in the last
ten years is extraordinary.
They leave because they see no clear
path to a leadership position.
It affects advocacy
and fundraising.
It's very hard for me, you know,
the people that I research on are
disproportionately
represented among the poor.
I don't have that constituency
that is rich.
If I don't have
people at the top,
I'm working for that who are truly and
generally and passionately interested.
And it's not lip service -
that is a problem.
Finally, there is conflict.
Unfortunately, at the current time,
most of the panels
that would solve these conflicts
do not include minorities.
And I can tell you that
I can attest to this,
that there are instances
where I really had wished
that there was somebody
from the minority who was involved.
The ultimate goal
of all these things,
and this was very well articulated
by the previous speaker, is to establish
an independent investigative
who you are, where you live.
Finally, this is a highly
competitive environment.
To say that any of you can do
this alone is delusional.
We're all grains of sand.
You have to find sources
of inspirational support.
To me, that's been my parents
who gave me two precious gifts.
One was my faith.
Faith takes you over everything.
And the second one is the spirit of
service, again the desire to serve.
The second is my wife.
In Latin America,
people are told to pray
to the guardian angel.
I did better than that.
I married mine.
Third, you need mentors. You need
mentors within your institution,
but mentors outside the
institution as previously mentioned,
are unbelievably helpful.
And I have three people,
senior people,
who took an interest in my career
early on and whose advice I treasure.
Finally, in my own circumstances,
thousands of people have died in my
country as a byproduct of violence.
There were many times
when I was in the Bronx,
in New York, here where my will falter
and my spirit are weakened.
Somehow I could see they're
angels urging me to go on.
I'm very fortunate
to lead a program
trying to
help elucidate causes of
respiratory diseases in Hispanics.
I think this is a privilege--
the final thing is
when I have a mentee,
and this is very important
in an environment like this,
many people thirst
for power and glory.
And they get lost.
That's all they care about.
I've seen this many times.
What for?
In Roman times when a general
came from a Turkish campaign,
there were two
slaves in his chariot;
one to hold his laurels
and the other one to whisper
that all glories are for him.
Never forget that.
So, my own belief - everybody has to
define what success is.
People are at their best when they are
able to see beyond themselves.
Jackie Robinson was the first African American
to play in the major leagues
said once that
"Life has no meaning
except for the impact that it
has on the lives of others."
I believe in that.
So everyone we know who has
his own definition of success,
to me you have to advance.
You have to be promoted.
You have to aspire to leadership.
But that is to help
others and to serve.
That is not for
something or a reason.
So to me, success is
honoring the memory
of those peoples
whom I lost by serving
those who remain.
Motivating others,
the young people
who will be here long after
we all leave, to serve others.
Trying to be a positive influence
and most of all supporting
along with my family.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
Okay. What time is it?
Well, I'll speak briefly about
some thoughts that reinforce some of the
things that have been said already
and focus on some other issues.
Just...how many of you
know what your job is?
Do you feel like you know?
And it's not really a rhetorical
question. What ran through your mind?
Because when I arrived I said
"Where's the faculty handbook?"
And there wasn't one at that time.
And I think there is one now.
And there was one little workshop
which focused on teaching mostly
and tried to explain what
Harvard undergrads were like.
And I was one, so it really was
not a very good job orientation.
And so the practical matter
is that you're a researcher,
a teacher, a manager of money,
of people, a psychologist
of those people.
You have the service component
which contributes to the governance
of this incredibly complex organization,
and you've got one little cog
that you're helping turn
in your department
at the beginning.
And it's an impossible job
description and you've been trained
in maybe the one researcher
aspect of it.
And so you've quickly got to figure out
how to handle all these different hats.
And you're not going to get
any formal education on it.
You can ask for advice
from people around you,
you can try and model the ones
that you think are most successful,
but you yourself are going to
have to figure out how to divide
your own abilities
and what you're going to put some
effort into training yourself on.
And I'm going to phrase it that way
because the faster
you train yourself
to wear these
different hats easily,
the more effective
you're going to be
in that you will spend less time
wasting time,
mismanaging things
or putting effort into places
where there's very little payoff.
And
this question of how you manage
your time is huge.
It's your most valuable resource.
And you're going to have
to be extremely defensive
of the time that you
spend on scholarship.
And everyone handles that
in a different way -
they do all their work and writing
at home in the evening,
which worked great for me until I had
kids and that became impossible.
Some people have
on their calendars,
you know, certain blocks that are
sacred - the door is closed,
the phone is off, your email
program is closed, and you're working.
And you don't let the
world distract you.
Because all of your
other aspects of your job -
especially teaching -
have shorter term deadlines that are
going to try and fill all available time
And the most common mistake
that I see junior faculty making,
and I was guilty,
is that you spend every
day in between lectures
preparing for lectures
for your first course.
And you prepare about
five times as much material
as you can possibly
deliver in an hour.
And you had wasted a day
where you could have spent two hours
preparing the right amount of material
for one hour of lecture,
and then the rest of your day
actually doing scholarship.
And so I say this,
and some people say
"You can't spend only two hours
preparing an hour lecture,"
but there was actually a
study done at Princeton
which I ran into in about
my second or third year
where they had pooled all of the
successful mid-career faculty,
extremely detailed survey on
how they spent their time.
And there was a very strong correlation
between people who had limited
time spent away from research
and then their eventual success,
which makes sense
It's just very easy to get caught up
in short term deadlines.
On navigating Harvard,
Harvard is a maze. It's impossible.
I mean now at least there are
things like a handbook
that can help point you in
directions to find things.
But resources are available
for almost everything
and the hard part is
trying to find them.
And so you'll ask
your senior colleagues
and department chairs
but things change,
and they won't know what's
available to you now today.
And so then you start finding
administration people who are--
you should get to know
who you should ask
what things are out there
and I'll just list a few.
There's a lot available
for child care,
for travel; Parents in a Pinch
I used today with my sick baby.
There's mortgage help.
There's a publication
fund for junior faculty -
$5000 to use towards publication
which I learned about this year,
and none of the other people in the
department knew about.
That's an FAS, yes,
so that is true.
There are differences
between schools.
And there's faculty aid.
So try and find out because these
things will make your life easier.
What you have at your advantage
by being here are the people.
And you have an incredible quality
of colleagues, quality of students,
quality of administrative
staff support that I know
from talking to my colleagues at other
schools that they just simply don't have
And it will save you time
if you learn how to use them.
Learn how to use your
assistants effectively
in management of your program
and in preparation for lectures.
And the more you can do that, the more
you will save time for your scholarship.
In terms of--
there's this question
about mentorships
and I agree. I go back and forth.
You're going to get
assigned a mentor
by someone at some time, or offered a
mentor or offered to be a mentor.
And you have to think about what you
want to get out of that relationship.
And you can get very good things
and at times it's so
artificial that it's not useful.
So what you want to do is keep your
eye out for the accidental mentor.
And then once you've found that
person, nurture that relationship.
But it won't come through one
of these arbitrarily assigned things.
And ideally it would be
someone who's not in your--
I go back and forth on
"in your department."
It would be great to also have
someone outside of your department
that you can talk to
because at some point
you will need help, and you will want
to admit to somebody that you need help.
And you're going to need that other
person out there to help you refocus.
And if you don't have that
person you'll spend a lot of time
being lost before
you can get back on track.
And I say that there's an
accidental mentor out there
because in your research,
in additional to
staying straight arrow
in what you're doing so that you
will actually accomplish something,
you want to keep yourself open -
through accidental conversations in
the department, at conferences -
for those seeds of new projects that
you could only do because you're here.
And you do that
by talking to people.
You ask people what they're doing;
you have something that's on your
mind now that you tell them about.
And every once in awhile it leads to a
click and you've got a whole new project
in a new direction that you wouldn't
have gotten if you weren't at Harvard.
And so keep yourself
receptive to that
in addition to having
your focus program.
But you're going to
have to make a decision
and it needs to be
a conscious decision -
are you changing your research
program to take advantage of it,
or are you staying on track and saving
it for later or keeping it limited?
But those kinds of decisions that
you make in these first few years
need to be conscious and not--
What I'm trying to say is that
you don't let your career
be a little bit of a random walk
in these early stages.
My advice on
this getting to your
associate promotion
is generally not to think about it
in that thinking about tenure,
thinking about promotions
is not in itself a good
use of your energy
unless you're reviewing your focus
which is going to help the
promotion process but not--
don't do it because of a review.
You're doing it because you're
keeping yourself focused.
And the main reason why you
don't want to think about it
is because the criteria is
something ridiculous.
You need to be great.
My parents ask me
"What's involved in being promoted?"
I have to be great in something.
And that's an impossible
definition to work toward,
and it goes to Juan's very
good point on why are you here.
And it's not because you
want to get promoted,
because it's an
impossible standard.
There's no concrete definition
to measure yourself against.
And so you're doing something
because of your passion
for your research and your
other personal reasons.
And so,
on being great means knowing
really what your contribution is,
what your main questions are,
and you're trying to develop
relationships internally
so that people in the department
know why you're great.
Because everyone's
in a different field
they're not necessarily
going to appreciate
what's so great about what you're
doing, and it's okay to tell them.
And then nurturing your
relationships outside of Harvard,
which will be the most important
when you come up for a review
so that they know why you're great
and that you have a good established
presence outside of Harvard,
which means you have to balanc
e your time away from here
at meetings as well as here.
And in regards to
thinking about money,
raising money, recognition, trying to
get appointments on important panels,
committees those things follow good
research and having good relationships.
And you don't seek
them out directly.
You focus on your program and
being known for something.
You focus on having good,
strong, professional relationships,
and then things will
follow directly from that.
The money follows the good work.
I'll say I had two kids
on tenure track;
three-and-a-half years
old and a half-year-old.
It's possible.
My time management skills
went through the roof
once I had kids.
Before that it was a
waste of time everywhere,
and after that I
really got focused.
So that's one strategy but
maybe not the best strategy
for learning how to manage your time.
And I'll end there.